is a patriot no okay I don't know what
that guy is okay I don't even know what
he is I hear the name the name is
popular I think he's done a great job of
like making himself be mysterious and
not even in the conversation I think
like The Wizard of Oz yeah it's like
it's like it's like just now with the
internet like think about this this is
fascinating this is how you know that
guy got some influence and control
we know everything about Jeffrey Epstein
everything about Gillian Maxwell I got
bikini pictures of Elaine Maxwell right
yeah you do nobody even knows George
Soro they barely know his upbringing
they kind like this if this guy is
actively supporting these uh district
attorneys in these liberal cities and
destroying the fabric of these liberal
cities and these liberal states if he's
doing that and we got one picture of him
that's different level
and it and it is possible that a guy
like that
is at odds with the people that want
America to be successful and he's found
a way to profit
off of this and who know I don't know
why they would even let a guy like that
exist
if there is an all-powerful day that's
trying to protect America why would they
let him exist
who the [__] is he can you tell me who
he is oh there's no way in the world
like right now if you're looking are you
familiar with ESG d-e-i and CEI no is
that anything I didn't even know what
the [__] you just said
let's talk about tequila the best kind
of tequila I don't know if you guys had
it this last yeah
afterwards uh so apparently these guys
if you're not they they they're
mixologists is what you guys are yeah
it's this protein drink am I saying it
correctly yeah yeah with Celsius and
tequila is what you guys drinking
everything so impressed by this which
yeah
okay so
um
she a a CEI and Dei okay ESG is about
environmental something something group
that's out there to making sure
companies are making the right decisions
so Larry Fink uh and BlackRock say
things like we're gonna force people to
do the right thing there's a video of
him saying this we have to use Force to
make companies do the right thing Dei is
called your diversity equity and
inclusive score how good of a job you do
here this will be a good score
all around this will be a great score
here okay yeah except one of you got two
of you guys has to be gay
okay yeah so then you have CEI corporate
Equity index score okay so what the hell
does this mean
so
villamovania okay yeah goes out there
and gets the drinks from Bud Light yeah
didn't do anything wrong okay tell him
any just got the box
great yeah so Dylan does what Dylan does
and he's on Drew Barrymore and he's
doing all this stuff and yeah he's doing
his you know stretches and all these
weird stretches that we can't do and
anyway so Bud Light comes in he's
drinking people on the other side lose
their minds what the hell was this all
about yeah why are you doing in the VP
of marketing for Anheuser Bush comes out
and says well look here's what we have
to do let's face it a lot of the beer
drinkers are these frat you know we just
kind of have to find another audience
and we couldn't do with this what the
hell are you talking about who drinks
Bud Light you forgot who your audience
is no problem they did that to get a
higher ESG score because Anheuser-Busch
is one of only 20 companies in America
with a perfect 100 score so watch what
happens then the CEO of Anheuser-Busch
former Marine former CIA officer okay is
the anheus and has Anheuser-Busch CEO
sharp guy comes out and they do the
horse commercial okay they're like no
we're going back to horses you know more
horses and then he makes a statement
about the fact that we're this we love
America we do all this other stuff
perfect Bud light's numbers are down 28
percent
28 percent Coors Light is up then when
Bud Light is now backtracking about the
fact that they lost their customers
which is vets Americans just regular
beer drinkers who don't even think about
politics yeah I just want to have a beer
I love America then when he made the
apology and the ESG folks took it as
apology
they said nope Anheuser-Busch officially
lost their perfect score they had a
chance to stand up for themselves and
really do something about this and
defend the transgender Community they
did not we're lowering their score okay
so now it's like what the hell do we do
here's a here's the problem what they
did rather than understanding who your
audience is and making sure your
audience is happy with the customer with
the product that you're selling you're
trying to make ESG happy so who's Beyond
ESG Larry Fink BlackRock all these guys
but the HRC score which is the you know
the the the the Dei score and the CI
score HRC is a company that gives these
scores HR is a human rights something if
you Google what HRC stands for I don't
know what the C stands for it's human
rights Community human rights yes Human
Rights Campaign Human Rights Campaign
Human Rights Campaign goes and gives the
scores and they tell you what you need
to do to improve your score of ESG in
within your company so guess who gave
100 million dollars to HRC I want to say
2012 you can verify this in 2012 HRC
that dictates what your scores are and
comes and scores these people was given
100 million dollars by this guy named
George last name Soros okay so okay so
what Pat what's the big deal behind this
so you know then we go to a completely
different space you look at Hollywood
what announcement they just made right I
don't know if you guys saw the
announcement they made last week
Hollywood made an announcement of the
academies made an announcement last week
moving forward
for you to be considered to win an Oscar
you have to have a third of your crew or
the main actors or even Supporting Cast
or even people behind the camera be part
of the
underrepresented community which the
underrepresented community is lgbtq I
think it's women it's black it's
disabled it's all these things that they
have right yeah if you don't have a
third be a part of that guess what you
are not able to get nominated for an
Oscar which means uh you know if we go
to Titanic would have never been
nominated and would have never won if we
go to Godfather it's not going to happen
if we go to all the you know Saving
Private Ryan not going to happen you go
to all these great movies that have won
Oscars that'll never happen so what does
this do a Richard Dreyfus comes out and
says wait a minute what are you talking
about the whole concept of being
creative was for me to be let loose so I
can do what I'm doing by the way here's
the part that Hollywood has completely
lost our minds do you know why movies in
America went to Hollywood do you know
the story behind why we make movies in
Hollywood in the 20s you would hire the
Jews so the Jews went out in Hollywood
but where did they escape from where did
they live and who dictated the rules you
know who dictated the rules of Hollywood
and movie making oh a guy named Thomas
Edison from Jersey
they left Jersey because Thomas Edison
had all these guidelines of making stuff
that you had to do you have to go
through this you have to go through that
they controlled all of it you can type
in Thomas Edison 1920 Jersey Hollywood
leaving you'll see the article
so they go to Hollywood Edison like the
light bulb like the Edison Edison yes
Edison wow
did you did you find the article Edison
yeah I'm pulling it up right now yeah
it's Edison the light bulb Edison guy
yeah forces the creatives I'm like dude
let me alone let me just go make what I
want to make why are you doing this to
me let's go find this one city called
Hollywood they go to Hollywood in 1920
95 of all Motion Picture movies were
made in Hollywood they gave the double
to Jersey and to Edison they go to
Hollywood
they make the movies today
yep
the film industry to Hollywood wow they
left him so here's what's crazy from 95
of Motion Pictures being built in
Hollywood to Now 50 55 people are
leaving Hollywood to different cities
they're sick of this game that's being
played so people forget like go back and
figure out why Hollywood started in the
first because you made it too difficult
to make movies here now you're doing it
again you're doing it why what does
George want from this is he profit
driven like I I don't understand his uh
my own opinion yes please what is your
own opinion for me okay so
there's a lot of different fears people
have there's a lot of different fears
people have you know there's a fear
about overpopulation oh that's one of
the biggest fears that we have with
overpopulation Elon Musk comes out and
talks about the other population yeah we
need people declining population if you
go really look at the founder of Planned
Parenthood and see what the hell her
vision was and how she was worried about
all these kids being made and if you see
her interview with Wallace just go watch
this 26 minute interview with Wallace
and you'll see what she says when he
asks the question do you believe there's
such a thing as a sin do you think we're
committing sins by preventing these kids
no I think we're doing the right thing
because these kids shouldn't be born in
this difficult life and all this other
stuff no problem statistically speaking
and then morally speaking I'll give you
statistically first and then we'll go
morally statistically China when you
look at their population a a inverted
pyramid is
when a society is healthy meaning a a
pyramid is where Society is healthy
meaning the youngest at the bottom zero
to four in China in 1950 the biggest
percentage of the China's population
1950 can pull this up as well was zero
to four yeah okay then it's five to
eight and all this other stuff right
when you look at their age so today
China is a complete opposite they have
tons of old people talk about young
people to support them and their cost of
Medicare just 20 years ago was half a
trillion dollars last year was eight
trillion dollars they don't know what to
do with this they're dealing with this
four to one rule which is for every one
kid he has to take care of two of his
parents and four of his grandparents but
1978 1979 they came up with the one
child policy China took it they used to
do four five six kids yeah per announce
1.1 is where they are so in U.S you
didn't want to do they wanna oh [__] is
this our Democratic freeway of combating
a rising population by getting you see
what China is well this is the [__] that
I'm talking about this is just a second
we were talking about how do you plan
out a hundred years and who are these
figures that are planning out 100 years
in America we can't say you're just
going to have one you're just gonna have
one kid because we put freedom in the
[__] constitution in the beginning
and I know the powers that be right now
like what [__] idiots did that 1776
this made my life so difficult now I got
to manipulate Americans into doing
something that they might not want to do
through the guise of Freedom right so
holy [__] they see the advantage that
China might have by reducing their
population we have to find a way to
reduce our population and now you've got
women on the streets going to scoop
those babies out of your uterus by the
way that's one girl [__] would be one
element you know what the other one is
here's what the other one is gays
No More by the way you saw what Bill
Moore talked about have you ever seen
the statistic by generation which
generation has the most lgbtq members
have you seen this can you pull up lgbtq
community community by Generations okay
and then he Bill Maher says listen at
this pace by 2000 47 we're all going to
be gay okay because that's just kind of
it used to be point five percent then
one percent of the generation then it's
two percent and it's four percent and
it's five percent then now it's like 24
of the generation of is is LGBT so the
pushback someone would give for this
argument is those were times when being
gay was not accepted and now is the time
when it's being accepted so all those
people that were in the closet have now
come out the closet that's the pushback
that someone give to that statistic and
the flip on that would be there's a
major uh churches are losing today to
the Church of lgbtqology okay these guys
are baptizing people into their
Community better than anybody else is
doing it at a guest on the podcast from
uh gays against groomers this guy was on
he says I'm gay totally gay our
communities we're all gay you know
lesbians and gays is what we are but
here's what we don't like we don't like
putting that into people's thoughts
people schooling like books right now uh
you buy book it's called it's normal uh
or jbc's and it says here's how boys
have sex with boys at 10 years old
here's how girls will have sex with
pictures and images in the book by the
way yeah and you know some parents are
sitting there saying look man it's a few
things you got to know I teach my kids I
raise my kids it ain't your job this
ain't no Village these are not your kids
these are my kids so you either have to
subscribe to the fact that these are
your kids are America's kids or your
kids are your kids if you subscribe to
the idea that your kids are America's
kids let them groom your kids no problem
be at it but if you think these are your
kids then you gotta raise your kids with
the valuesome principles that you got
yeah you pick and choose that is a form
that is a philosophy that you got to
make a decision which one you're more
comfortable with a lot of parents are
not this is why people are moving to
Florida and this is why some of the guys
are more comfortable being in Florida
than in some of these other states some
states are fighting this so again going
back to this this conversation started
with George foreign
then coming down to the depopulation all
this stuff who knows what their motives
are but some are thinking this could be
one of them and that's George Soros
wants to depopulate in America George
Soros once an open Society because he is
a globalist that does would like to have
an open borders open Society if you
Google open Society Foundation that's
the foundation that gave HRC 100 million
dollars he started open society and why
would that benefit him and the people
that agree with him how would that
benefit him and the people
I don't think it's about how but we can
go there as well and by the way
everything I'm saying from here on is
purely opinion and speculation
um feelings no facts on this show yeah
that's great I love it no but you know
look would some people who are driven by
power would they rather control 330
million people oh [__] or 8 billion
people so okay so here's where we go
most people regardless if if we think
they are good or bad
convince themselves that they are being
benevolent
nobody goes I'm a bad guy we agree right
I totally agree so where does he see his
benevil so two nights ago whatever the
night was when the Celtics played Miami
Heat and the Celtics beat him what was
that two nights ago I didn't tune into
the game I watched the George Soros
documentary came 2019 four years ago
worth watching starts up with painting
him as an evil guy ends with he's a
philanthropist cares about the world
cares about America well here goes to
another Chelsea Handler's Handler story
for you when his mom when he was a young
kid I think he was nine years old and
his mom
had two I want to say
Russians or two Germans I think Germans
raped his mother
and she told him the story and he is
apparently lived out with the story you
know those kinds of enemies the Loyalty
isn't to you the loyalties into anything
the loyalty is to that happened to my
mom and my mom sold me disbeliefs and my
mom believed in me I'm going to spend
the rest of my life making sure my mom's
dream becomes a reality because that is
an emotional story that I'm going to
tell myself over and over and over again
until it becomes a reality right like
what was his mom's dream uh uh it's not
about what his mom's dream was his mom's
you know the hatred she had the the pain
that the mom and the trauma she went
through by being raped by two German
soldiers I think is German or Russian
you can look it up on which one it is so
in the documentary they're kind of
telling that story and then he
eventually reads a book by a man I don't
know his name that talks about the
concept of open Society if you type in
George Soros open Society you know the
book he read it'll come up more
accepting and open we are with one
another yes the less chance that this
will ever happen again yes to anybody
not just someone that I care about
the yeah okay that's right there Carl
poppers 1945 book The Open society and
its enemies